sometimes TV actors find themselves in
scenes that produce a very real fear
response from dangerous stunts to jump
scares that proved way too hard jolting
these have the TV scenes that terrified
actors in real life signing up for Game
of Thrones pretty much guarantees that
you'll be trading blows and blades
eventually that action component
appealed to Ian Glenn who played jorah
mormont the disgraced Knight who
transitioned from spying on Daenerys to
becoming one of her most loyal servants
as Glen explained L he loves stage
fighting but he was intimidated by the
scale of jurors gladiatorial scene which
saw him take on multiple adversaries in
the same hectic sequence he said I was
pretty fearful when it's that extensive
of a fight I was fighting various people
with different weapons things can happen
accidents can happen fortunately
everything worked out and the scene
became one of Glenn's favorite memories
of working on the show he told
Entertainment Weekly the whole
gladiatorial sequence it was a very hard
week and I loved doing that so for the
action side of things that sequence
encapsulated it my little girl was there
you know she watched a pupper work David
sent out you know comes here you can
call it shoe she was like while that may
have been the scariest scene to shoot a
different one proved too much to even
watch Glenn admitted to variety that he
couldn't bring himself to watch Jorah
fight in the Battle of Winterfell
because he was too emotionally invested
in the character Breaking Bad never
shied away from grisly and tragic deaths
but there was one that really shook up
the cast and crew
Krysten Ritter knew from the start that
her character Jane had to die but the
scene where it happened in which Jane
chokes on her own vomits after taking
heroin was rough for everyone involved
Ritter said the during shooting the crew
struggled to watch the terrifyingly
authentic scene and that she had to take
breaks because it was too overwhelming
her mother can't even talk about it
another parent who struggled with the
scene was Bryan Cranston he said that as
he was watching Ritter pretending to
choke he suddenly saw his own daughter
in her place his worst fear coming to
life it's the one scene from a very dark
show that still makes him emotion
Jane's death was also Aaron Paul's worst
seem his character Jessie tries to
revive her which involved Paul pounding
on Ritter's chest while she wore a
special rig talking about that scene in
2019
Paul said he and Ritter cried during
shooting adding I just couldn't come
back from it usually the only person
safe from a jump-scare induced heart
palpitation is the person jumping out
but Victoria pedretti is so good at
playing a ghost that she even scared
herself and one especially heart
lurching scene in the Netflix series the
haunting of Hill House but dready plays
now one of the inhabitants of the
titular house who survives the ghosts in
her childhood home only to die when she
returns as an adult later on in the
series Nels sisters get into an argument
while driving to the Haunted Mansion and
Nels Ghost bursts between their seats
shrieking like well a very distraught
ghost pedretti told decider that nel
wasn't trying to scare her sisters as
she explained it came from a deeper
place and a real need so that's why it's
so loud and immediate I knew it was
happening and I screamed at myself but
it's still terrified everyone involved
her co-star Oliver Jackson Coen
confessed that watching it got him to
telling PopSugar I watched that episode
the other day and I was so so scared nel
broke me if you shut her when watching a
character die in a spectacular ly
gruesome way spare a thought for the
actor living the scene especially when
it comes to the cast of The Walking Dead
the zombie show has delivered some of
the most grisly deaths on TV but maybe
the most shudder inducing of all was
watching Geoffrey Morgan's negan stabbed
Austin Nichols Spencer in broad daylight
in season 7 Nichols wasn't crazy about
that moment either he was patted with a
special chest blade and a bag filled
with fake blood and guts but Morgan had
to use a real razor to split open the
back the actor told Entertainment Weekly
I was afraid he would puncture the chest
blade and actually cut me because he
comes at me really hard and really fast
luckily Morgan got it right in the first
and only tank while dying was scary
coming back as a zombie was all fun
Nichols revealed it was cool to do all
this fun stuff with the zombie makeup
and zombie contacts
after his characters dramatic death was
over he said I just stood up and started
screaming and I just started yelling
yeah that was awesome
like everyone who isn't an aspiring
medium Gabourey Sidibe prefers her
ghosts to be special effects but a
supernatural experience made her think a
real spirit showed up for one scene in
American Horror Story coven in episode
12 City Bay's character queenie recites
a latin spell to conjure an audience
with papa legba the gatekeeper to the
spirit world during an evening with the
women of American Horror Story Sidibe
said that as she spoke the words the
light fixture above her began to shake
while shooting another part of the scene
the light fixture crashed to the floor
and she felt a finger running up her
chin to her bottom lip which started to
swell Sidibe and a makeup artist went to
a trailer and started hearing scratching
noises on the walls outside they only
stopped when the makeup artist set a
prayer and clapped her hands completely
freaked out
Sidibe refused to say the Latin
summoning words again but she relented
when the other actors struggled to get
the hang of them this time her top lip
swelled up one of the first victims of
the ever-growing mind flayer and
stranger things season 3 was Heather the
lifeguard played by Francesca reali in a
telepathic trance 11 finds Heather in a
bathtub full of ice where she pleads for
help before being dragged down into the
water by an unseen force shooting the
first half of the scene was creepy for
reali who spent a day quote drowning
herself in the bathtub and things only
got scarier for the part of the scene
where Heather is pulled underwater reali
told cinema blend doing the drowning was
actually in a pool with a black bottom
which was terrifying for me because I
hate any body of water that has a black
bottom
adding to the waking nightmare there is
a mechanism attached to her foot which
pulled her down she had to hold her arms
above her head like she was reaching for
11and scream both without creating
bubbles while keeping her eyes open
ree-ally admitted that it was quote
incredibly hard but she said that she
enjoyed the chance to do a stunt and
she's game for more chilling Adventures
of Sabrina leans much more heavily into
occult practices in the show's bright
and bubbly
predecessor and despite playing powerful
witch prudence on screen Tati Gabrielle
says she got chills when it came time to
act out the resurrection ritual in
season 1 the ritual the group performs
involves walking deep into a dense
forest in the dark standing on a
pentagram lit by candles and chanting
black magic spells to summon spirit
hounds buying for witches but the
atmosphere made for a spine-tingling
shoot as a student of necromancy I
strongly advise that you recite the text
word for word the slightest deviation we
could all wind up dead Gabrielle
confessed to kudamon magazine I was
super terrified being out there at night
repeating these spells that are very
real spells and feeling like we're
calling on these weird dark forces we
prayed before we started the scene
because the show draws on real magical
practices
Gabrielle worried that she might be
messing with actual spirits she admitted
to Collider I get freaked out sometimes
when I go home at night thinking that a
demon is gonna be lurking at the corner
of my room vampires aren't afraid of
much but the humans who play them have
very real concerns natasha de metrio who
plays the vampire Nadya in the
mockumentary series what we do in the
shadows didn't feel so hot when a fire
effect didn't go as planned I just you
know this not much scares me about this
in a scene in the season 1 finale 3
Staten Island vampires visit a church
where they slowly start to burn up
Dimitrios hands really were set on fire
and she wore gloves covered in a special
paste that's supposed to burn without
damaging skin but the fire started
getting out of control she explained the
stuff they thought I was just doing it
as part of the scene so it was like a
good 5 seconds of me thinking I was
going to lose my hand showrunner Jemaine
Clemente thought the accidental effects
looked great but Demetrio understandably
broke with her character under fire
admitting I definitely ruined it by
screaming help help in my English accent
not all monsters are supernatural
Netflix's mind hunter explores the fbi's
early attempts to understand what makes
serial killers tick jonathan groff plays
hostage negotiator turned serial killer
investigator holden ford who's based on
the real-life FBI
Johnny Douglas in the show board forms a
strange bond with real-life killer Edie
Kemper played too terrifying affect by
Cameron Britain at six foot nine Kemper
was physically imposing and he had a
high IQ he was chillingly eloquent in
his descriptions of the violent crimes
he committed watching the real Kemper or
Britain's version describe his
motivations as spine-tingling
especially if you're in the room
director and producer David Fincher
deliberately kept Britain apart from the
rest of the cast to make their scenes
even more intense
Groff admitted to rolling stone to be
sitting in this room with him in Los
Angeles all by myself was terrifying
in particular Groff was freaked out by a
scene in the season 1 finale where
Kemper hugs Ford gruff told Esquire that
when he was just reading the scene with
Britten the hair stood up on the back of
my neck that final scene was easy to act
because he is truly terrifying
excessively creepy clowns have become a
scourge of movies and TV in the last few
years and two of the more famous clown
trendsetters are American Horror Story
freak shows twisty and his accomplice
dandy who burst onto our screens in 2014
these clowns even scared Horror Story
veteran Emma Roberts she had nightmares
when shooting the show and when she saw
twisty her perfectly normal response was
he's gonna chase me through a forest at
4:00 a.m. in the middle of nowhere I
don't I don't think so
in fact Roberts character Maggie isn't
chased through a forest by twisty
instead it's dandy who's wearing a
different but also horrifying clown
costume it didn't take much acting to
get that scene right you get this
adrenalin a fear where you're like oh my
god I know it's fake but he's right
behind me and it's really scary
truebloods Tara Thornton went through a
lot in a relatively short life but the
scariest scene for actress Rutina Wesley
was the one in which Sookie and
Lafayette buried Tara hoping to bring
her back as a vampire after she was
killed saving Sookie Tara is dead in the
scene but Wesley definitely wasn't and
like anyone with a pulse she didn't
enjoy being buried alive in fact she
nearly had a panic attack but since dead
people can't breathe much less
hyperventilate she had to stay as still
as possible she explained to flare
I remember my heart was beating so fast
it took all my focus not to move an inch
when the final shovel of dirt was thrown
on my face I think I might have actually
inhaled some dirt that day although it
was terrifying at the time Wesley later
admitted to vulture it turned out to be
a beautiful shot that's how you get it
you'd do it for real check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]